What are the factors of a number?
How do we find out if a number is a factor of another?
Is 'four' a factor of '24'.
To know if 4 is a factor of 24,
we simply divide 24 by 4 and find out if the remainder is 0 or not .
Is the remainder 0 here?
If we divide 24 by 4,
we get the quotient as 6 and the remainder as 0.
So what does this imply?
After the division if the remainder equals '0',
it tells us that the divisor is a factor of the dividend.
Since the remainder is 0 here,
We say that 4 is a factor of 24.
It also means that 24 is divisible by 4.
Or you can say that 24 goes exactly into 4.
In short the factor of a number is an exact divisor of that number.
Now I would like you to answer the next question.
Is 5 a factor of 24?
To know the answer,  let's try dividing 24 by 5.
5 times 4 is 20.
And 24 minus 20 gives us 4.
We get the quotient as 4 and the remainder as 4.
Since the remainder is not 0, we can say that 5 is not a factor of 24.
That's how we find out if the number is a factor of another or not.
How else can we understand this?
The fact that 4 is a factor of 24
tells us that 24 can be divided into 4 equal parts.
And the fact that 5 is not a factor of 24,
tells us that 24 cannot be divided into five equal parts.
A factor is nothing but an exact divisor of a number.
Now let me ask you another interesting question.
How will you find all the factors of 24?
Take a moment and think about this.
We cannot try dividing 24 by all numbers
and see if we get the remainder as 0 in each case.
That would be very tedious!
So yes, there is a better way in which we can find the factors of a number.
We see that in the next session.